retrouvez la p'tite tabou la grande
table la grande la grande table aller
chercher les gens ramener la petite si
c'est un magasin alors prochains jours
une bonne table on fait ça on combien en
3.3 propre gagnant au 5 % pour gagner on
a passé un point gagnant 5 points
gagnants caisse klm à lévis et a dit toi
tu n'aurais pas pu la lui non plus
[Applaudissements]
et bien ici tu te fais tout petit le
vendredi du pouvoir tels john ont dominé
tu fais quoi dans la vie
sans profession sans profession voilà
mon chéri écoute moi bien si je gagne je
gagne ta chemise il la donne tout de
suite si je perds je te le dis je
t'envoie pour un séjour magnifique
[Applaudissements]
kind of time code est ce que quelqu'un
un portable s'il vous plaît oui oui
là bas j'étais cramé et arrêter de dire
que c'est un grand oui tiens c'est un
grand match on a des balles on joue
s'emballe merci à mon âge
et toi de te dit tu me donnes ta chemise
je te le dis tout ça qui suit la
bienvenue je veux faire une balle
d'échauffement alors je vais te dire
c'est l'aval des show poche la paire
toujours pour mettre en confiance un
gars étaient prêts tu me dis que tu es
prêt alors cinq fois c'est parti c'est
bon
jouer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donnez-moi porte à plus gros porte à
plus gros t'as pas il ya pas l'autre
modèle mais je vais bien à tulle à toi
tu passerais pas avec ça mais qui ici le
mével a donné à lui à 0
tu as raison bastia je me donnais mois
pour cadre le duo d'amis deluna vous me
trouvez ça la motion est en tout cas on
repart à zéro il ya 2 0 105 quoi vous
inquiétez pas bah oui c'est bon auteur
[Applaudissements]
ces 2 1 2 1
qu'est-ce que je kifferais avoir ta
chemise
et les bois c'est d'aller faire en trois
points
allez hop
attends 410 points calamiteuse 3 que
faire du big bang toutes les missions la
vas-y mai à paris
c'est là
la mission qu'à toi tu étais cochon
aider la nature simplement célèbre
[Applaudissements]
ces jours